25 millions d'habitants confinés à
shanghai 17 millions à shenzhen 9
millions à chang chun 1.5 million à
beijing nous ne sommes pas en 2020 mais
bien en 2022 depuis début mars les
confinements parfois très strictes se
succèdent en chine qui fait tout pour
empêcher l'apparition de nouveaux 99
c'est la stratégie du zéro co vide et la
chine est l'un des derniers pays à la
mettre en oeuvre les habitants sont de
plus en plus inquiets parce que il ne
voit pas d'horizon même s'il faut
toujours se méfier des chiffres
communiqués par la chine pékin fait face
depuis début avril à une sévère
augmentation des cas de contamination au
coc u19 similaire au pic de la toute
première vague il ya deux ans en 2020
pourquoi alors le pays s'accroche-t-il à
cette stratégie qui pourrait durer
encore longtemps
réponse dans facture
en france les cas positifs ne cesse
d'augmenter depuis début mars atteignant
aujourd'hui 140 mille cas quotidiens les
hospitalisations elles ont recommencé à
augmenter fin mars pourtant chez noni
confinement ni masque ni politique de
tests massif ni quasi fermeture des
frontières c'est ce qu'on appelle la
stratégie de mitigation nous vivons avec
le virus qui circule en chine par contre
c'est tout l'inversé et après trois ans
de pandémie et de restrictions la
stratégie du zéro co vide semble
atteindre ses limites
cette politique draconienne vise à
empêcher la parution de nouveaux 2,99 à
travers notamment des confinement à
répétition dès qu'un foyer de
contamination est repéré des campagnes
de dépistage massif l'isolément et la
mise en quarantaine systématiques des
malades et la fermeture de certaines
frontières cette stratégie du tester
tracé isolé poussé au maximum c'est à
dire que on ne l'acceptent pas qu'ils
aient une seule chaîne de contamination
qui ne sont pas sous contrôle le 14 mars
notre correspondant en asie écrivait
dans le figaro aller au bureau prend des
allures d'expédition à hauts risques il
faut emporter une valise de survie au
cas où on se retrouve bloquée dans les
locaux chaque jour nombre d'habitants
embarque avec eux couverture et
victuailles pour tenir un siège par
crainte d'être confiné d'office
quant au micro et détecter quelque part
les autorités boucle les immeubles sans
ménagement quelques jours plus tard un
strict confinement été réinstaurée à
shanghai des milliers de soignants et
l'armée ont été envoyés en renfort pour
mener des tests de dépistage des halls
d'exposition de la métropole ont été
transformés en centre de quarantaine
comme en 2020 le building
celle
ci
[Musique]
on saura blanc et des formules états
unis
mais pourquoi alors la chine s'obstine
tel à ne pas laisser le virus circulait
première raison la faiblesse de la
couverture vaccinale des chinois si vous
prenez deux doses dustin aux formes de
sinovac vous êtes moins bien vacciné
qu'avec deux doses de vaccin arn
messager mais vous êtes quand même très
protégée et si vous prenez trois doses
vous êtes aussi bien protégés que avec
le vaccin et rennes ne s'agit donc en
fait simplement il faut trois doses pour
être bien vaccinés le problème des
chinois où c'est qu'ils n'ont pas réussi
à vacciner toute la population avec la
même ferveur que en occident alors qu'en
france à peu près 80 3 % des plus de 65
ans ont reçu un schéma vaccinal complet
avec une dose de rappel qu'en chine il
ya seulement 40% des gens de plus de 60
ans qui ont obtenu une troisième dose
cette troisième dose est considéré comme
très importante pour pouvoir assurer une
protection relativement forte contre le
virus d'ailleurs les personnes âgées ou
vulnérables sont nombreuses à craindre
les effets secondaires du vaccin et
beaucoup ont été dissuadés par des
médecins de se faire vacciner il est
donc très compliqué pour la population
chinoise d'atteindre l'immunité
collective tant convoité dont les pays
occidentaux se rapproche
deuxièmement les hôpitaux très vite
surchargés évidemment l'autre united
majeur des lots en jeu by capacités
hospitalières la chine est encore un
pays en développement ça c'est autre
qu'on a tendance à oublier mais ce sont
encore des structures sanitaires très
rudimentaire cette peur extrême de voir
le virus circule et est en partie dû au
traumatisme de la chine lors du début de
l'épidémie haoran mais elle est aussi
due à la forte propagande du régime qui
a persuadé de nombreux chinois que le
virus était mortel même pour les
personnes en très bonne santé ce qui a
pu provoquer des situations qui ont
indigné
beaucoup de chinois depuis quelques
jours des vidéos circulent sur les
réseaux chinois elles montrent des
enfants et des bébés séparés de leurs
parents dans ce qui semble être un
centre de quarantaine des vidéos ont
beaucoup choqué sur web au soleil
sociaux de plus en plus de commentaires
critiquant cette pratique séparer les
enfants positif de leurs parents
éventuellement négatives et les
autorités en ont conscience issue à
l'instant même donc je vous parle on
vient d'apprendre par exemple qu'à
shanghai les autorités municipales bien
venez d'annoncer qu'ils allaient ouvrir
un centre où les parents auraient le
droit d'accompagner leurs enfants
positif en quarantaine donc ça serait
une concession d'âge
enfin comme souvent il ya l'enjeu
politique on a aussi un calendrier
politique particulier en chine cette
année à l'automne va se tenir un grand
congrès du parti c'est le plus grand
rendez vous politique dans la chine
comme liste tous les cinq ans c'est un
petit peu comme l'élection
présidentielle en france les états unis
c'est là qu'ils ont affirmé que le
système chinois était le meilleur pour
endiguer qui dédie donc aujourd'hui
évidemment face à une recrudescence y
est ce que ça me met en échec la
politique zéro co vide le problème c'est
que cette stratégie semble asphyxier le
pays qui n'en finit pas de se battre
contre les variants du coït 19 mai le
gouvernement maintient coûte que coûte
sa stratégie du zéro côté parlement les
signaux qui viennent de paix cartes sont
des signaux plutôt décourageant sont des
signaux de fermeté on maintient la ligne
zéro covin le président shing là encore
dit récemment tente la stratégie
fonctionne en chine il ya très peu de
mort du co vide en ce moment alors ils
peuvent peut-être gagner le temps qui
leur permettrait de regagner les points
de vaccination des personnes âgées qui
leur manquent plupart des experts
estiment que la chine va rester ternes
et au moins j'étais à freiner mais ça
c'est le pronostic on va dire optimistes
autre pense que ça peut durer
avoir 2024 aujourd'hui on sait qu'on ne
pourra pas éradiqué le vide le zéro que
vides et probablement illusoire mais
encore une fois aujourd'hui les chinois
n'ont pas beaucoup le choix parce que
tant qu'ils n'ont pas vaccinés bien
leurs personnes âgées sont beaucoup trop
à risque les dirigeants chinois réfère
ne pas voir cette hécatombe sur le plan
social et pour raisons politiques
seraient effroyable en dehors du plan
sanitaire
[Musique]